welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for today's
presentation titled
broaden your applications with magnetic
bead
conjugation it's my pleasure to
introduce to you
tom lyons custom projects leader
genomics and diagnostic solutions
sativa for a complete biography on our
speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
so please join me in welcoming tom lyons
i will now turn the presentation
over to him welcome tom
hi uh thank you very much for that
introduction um
this is a presentation on the
application or the use of magnetic beads
um in your own applications in your
laboratories
and specifically the conjugation onto
those magnetic beads
so i'll skip right ahead from the first
slide and just go into a little bit on
the agenda and what to expect
so initially we wanted to cover in this
presentation was the sativa
organization a little bit and also the
site where we manufacture our magnetic
beads which is
cardiff in the uk um and being a centre
of excellence
uh for sativa it's one we're very proud
of so we just wanted to highlight
um a bit about the team there and just
sort of show off
to you guys then just in case we've got
any
people here or any scientists here who
haven't heard of the use
of magnetic particles we're going to
highlight a little bit about
paramagnetic properties and some of the
particles that we have
in our portfolio
after that we are going to look at the
applications
of magnetic beads specifically around
our portfolio um and what we hope you
guys are
uh doing in your laboratories and seeing
how
these might give you some ideas for some
further experiments
additionally we're going to cover the
conjugation of
our magnetic particles and a little bit
of focus on some
do's and don'ts as well as some ideas
for conjugation
and finally we were going to cover the
custom
services team customized solutions team
uh which i'm part of
and we we're going to talk about we're
going to i'm going to talk about
sorry how this team based in cardiff
where we manufacture the beads
can help you further the your
applications and get you that one step
closer to being able to use paramagnetic
beads for you
for your desired technique
so a little introduction slide and we'll
just go into the kardash site
so the main art center which as i said
is based in cardiff in the uk
has been manufacturing biopharma
particle or biopharma
materials for the sector for the past 40
years
it supplies to a global customer base
with over two and a half thousand
customers in the
research and diagnostic market each year
there are
90 000 sales of orders which are shipped
to customers each year and as i say
they're across the globe and on-site in
cardiff there's a team of over 200
people who are manufacturing
over 1500 products for you guys to
purchase
so it's a it's quite a big skype and
it's quite a busy site
the team which i'm part of is the
genomics and diagnostics
team sorry it's the genomics and
diagnostics business
and with a custom customized team who
are based within that group
there's a seven scientists in our team
who are all dedicated to the custom
projects
we work from university startups
all the way through to large biopharma
corporations
and we approach each custom product a
custom
opportunity with the same dedication and
the same
intention of output for you guys to get
a
product or a custom material specific
for your application
we can make
projects which go from very small proof
of principle scale
all the way up to full scale
manufacturing runs and that
depending on what application that is
will depend on what we make
and as of this year which has been a
busy year i think for all of us in this
sector
we've been working with more than 50
different organizations across the globe
to deliver custom products
so then i wanted to run on and describe
paramagnetic particles
so in here we've got a couple of nice
videos which you can find on youtube
just to have a look at how the particles
look and how they handle
inside a liquid which can help people
visualize things a little bit
but in principle um a paramagnetic
particle
is not like a magnet it doesn't
continually sit there and try
and attract itself to each other they're
paramagnetic
in that they only show magnetic
properties when they are within
a magnetic field so if you look at the
slide on the left where you see there's
a mixture of a solution with our
paramagnetic beads
they will sit there and be diffuse
and and effectively uh become a part of
the solution
then when you apply a magnetic field
this can be simply one of our
bench magnets uh which which we have
um or or a simple button magnet that
some people use
the beads are attracted to that magnet
and they are attracted to themselves so
they will start to
agglutinate towards each other and will
all be drawn into what is described as a
pellet
where the magnetic field is the
strongest
what you can then do is when you have
this pellet at the side of the vessel
you can remove any other liquid which
you don't want
or maybe you want to keep and the beads
have removed something you don't want
and you can add another solution back in
and by then
by releasing the magnetic field in other
words taking the vial
out of the um the magnetic stand
the beads will go back into solution and
that's one of the the key properties
of these paramagnetic particles
part of the family of paramagnetic
particles that we have are the ceramic
beads
and these are around one micron
in diameter it's a very um
mono dispersed size for them they're
super paramagnetic which means they have
a very strong magnetic
prop moment within a magnetic field and
all and and
simply zero magnetic properties when
there is no magnetic field
they have at this cauliflower like
surface which i'll describe on the next
slide just to help people visualize it
which is why they seem a little bit
rough on the on the surface
um key points for these are they have
excellent colloidal stability so
they're very uh very good
in aqueous solutions they don't like to
uh
clump up then they they dispen disperse
very well
um they have almost no
leaching properties of the materials
they're made of so they're very clean to
using diagnostic samples
and they're very easy to use but just
simple bench top magnets or as i said
button magnets can be used
so here we've got a tem of the surface
of our beads and as you can see
it looks very rough and ready and this
this rough surface this cauliflower like
surface
helps um some of the capture properties
which are quite unique to our beads and
helps them with the um
increased surface area that many people
comment on how our beads perform whether
that's
with a custom liquid on the surface of
them or whether it's our streptavidin
beads which are part of our catalogue
the ceramic product range is quite vast
um we
we sell um a large amount of them from
different with different functionalities
on them so i just wanted to give this
slide
for any researchers who are here who are
curious about where you can use these
particles
in your own applications so we cover
the areas of diagnostics genomics and
proteomics
diagnostics in with just our core
particles of carboxyl
beads uh which are the sort of the core
particle we have
and these can be functions with uh
functionalized
with oligos or streptavidin as well as
we have a second family which is the
core bead with another layer of
magnetite
added onto them so they are they will
move to the magnet even faster than the
standard bead
the genomics area we cover the um also
the oligobead
and the car box will be but also with an
extra focus on
the streptavidin surface now whether
that's streptavidin
um just on the bead but a further
blocking a chemical blocking of the gr
of the particles
for a streptavidin blocked bead and
finally
look at the proteomics area where
mostly it's focused on the streptavidin
neutrophidine
binding but we also have some bulk
protein ag
affinity beads as well
additionally to the uh ceramic family
there is the cyrosilmag family of
particles
and we have two in our catalogue as it
stands
a 700 nanometer and a 400 nanometer size
particle so these are our smallest
particles that we have in the catalog
um they are they are part of a silica
shell
um with magnetite inside the core
of the particles they are have a very
narrow
size distribution so they're all very
similar in size
um and they move exceedingly fast to
uh to a magnet so they're they're
probably are the
the most rapid um of the magnetic
particles
or the paramagnetic particles that we
have part of the portfolio
and additionally there is another uh
paramagnetic
part um product this is the
magsephrose particles and these are
based on
an agarose particle with a core of
magnetite or paramagnetic material in
the middle of the beads
these range of the size from 37 to 100
micrometer
so there's still quite a narrow size
distribution but specifically for the
bulk purification
of um
of of samples um based on the
agarose sepharose um particle um
uh sort of family of purifications
and a little bit more on how the
magcephros beads
the ceramic beads and the cirrus silmag
beads those silica particles
uh which i talked about on here so as
you can see there's many different
coatings for both the magsepheros and
the ceramic beads and the silica
particles we don't have any
specific functionalizations of them at
the moment it's just the silent surface
which is effectively a hydroxyl surface
on the bead
and so depending on your application
you're welcome to talk to us about that
if you have any further questions
you can see where we can help guide you
as to what
what type of bead might be most
appropriate for your application whether
that's nucleic acid
purification or protein purification
as well as some of the handling
sort of techniques you may want to have
with those particles
so further on from this we i wanted to
talk about
uh applications for magnetic particles
to give you an idea if you have current
particles maybe they're using um
96 well plates with some kind of solid
phase
um to to bind your sample out of a
solution or
your analyte of interest so i was going
to go
further into that in the next couple of
slides
but one thing which is very
useful for all of these um materials is
that
whether whether it's the ceramic family
of beads or the magcepharos
um specifically you can the the
modification of the surface of the
particles
is key to how they will perform in your
application
so whether that needs to have um
an affinity label for um or a
complementary label for
for a nucleic acid binding or maybe it's
uh binding some kind of probe onto the
surface of
of the of the particle along with the
magnetic bead to detect
um to detect it further downstream
the these are all the many modifications
which we've had experience
it with in the custom team um as well as
within the broader portfolio that we're
happy to help with
specifically uh i wanted to talk about
uh
the binding of um a
molecular probe uh with our poly tea
bead so
you as as we have part of our part of
our
portfolio has the oligo dt magnetic
particles
and this will bind to a poly a
um molecule or
oligo in your sample
what can further be done with that oligo
is it can you can then um
synthetically turn that oligo into a
poly a
but then with a specific sequence at the
end of the poly a
to bind to a target of interest and so
by using the poly the oligo dt bead
to bind your oligo sequence of interest
using the poly a affinity which is built
into the oligo gt
the poly a tail for want of a better
word
you can then make many different um
detection probes within your part
from the same particle but with many
different oligo sequences
using as i say that poly a affinity at
the end of them
and so this is quite a common technique
for binding out targets of interest
in solutions or even binding um rna
within solutions as well for further
downstream
applications
then another very common uh use of the
particles
is for immunoassay um be it diagnostics
or immunopurification
and here you will we you can bind a
capture antibody or a biotinylated
capture antibody depending on
what your tech how sensitive your
technique is to the biotin binding
sometimes
it can have some non-specific binding
associated with it and so you either
couple the
capture anti anti-antibody directly onto
the surface of the bead
or couple it with a biotin
streptavidin conjugation so that using
the streptavidin beads
in our portfolio to bind a biotinylated
capture antibody
this is then able to uh that capture
antibody will then be able to
have an affinity for your analyte of
interest
and further downstream using
a um a detection antibody
with some either fluorophore or
some uh enzyme to create a signal
depending on how much of the
detection antibody has been bound on the
surface of the
um beads and we just wanted to highlight
that to that particular sort of antibody
affinity purification in the next slide
after this where we've
we've we've got a little illustration of
um domain antibody expressed by e coli
and then using bag sepharose protein l
modified magsepheros
to bind out the domain antibody
from the um expression of
e coli and specifically in the
the illustration i just want to cover we
show
very high binding capacity and also
significant reductions in endotoxicity
or endotoxins
from the e coli expression
so a little bit of a description of what
we have here but if you look at the um
images in the bottom left we've used our
magseferose bound to protein l
then by adding the e coli
expression into a wave bag a cell
wave bag mixing them together
we then place it onto a um
flat uh sorry a a wave platform
which is a series of magnets which then
binds out
and then pulls out the protein l
magsepheros with any of the toxins which
have been bound to it
sorry with any of the dab the domain
antibody which has been bound to it
out of the solution and so what we found
in a very short period of time as you
can see from the um
uh graph
on the right hand side within a few
minutes we've bound
90 of the domain antibody out of the
solution
and we're able to then wash the whole
solution
with um an aleutian uh buffer a very
simple one
of uh citrate and there's and
we've done some further uh um
investigations to show that uh the
endotoxin reduction has
endotoxicity has been reduced sick by a
number of logs and the ehcp reduction as
well by a number of logs so
just just to highlight the use of beads
to
capture a material of interest
and to remove any contaminants you may
find in your assays or expressions
so this would be a bulk purification
example
so with what we have from there are a
couple of examples of using
magnetic beads for uh specific
applications
but obviously there's many many
applications and and
what one thing we're quite proud of with
our um
ceramag and the cyrosil mag and the
magcephros technologies that they are
they are quite broad in their
capabilities
um once they have been modified
examples of modifications that we have
for our particles or modifications that
we can offer
um we can offer a modification of the
concentration
typically they're supplied at one
percent or five percent
uh solid content and we can describe the
solid content
um to anyone if they'd like some more
information
um the formulation or the buffer that
they're supplied in
whether they would like to be conjugated
to a specific enzyme or antibody or
oligo or custom ligand
we are happy to discuss and investigate
custom particles for your specific
applications be those modifications of
the size of the particles or some other
function
we have used our particles
for freeze drying or lyophilization
of them and whether that be with a
custom function on them
or whether that be just the standard
core particle
additionally as i said the cardiff site
is a large
site and a center of excellence that we
have within sativa
and so modifications of the pack sizes
or um number of
uh number of materials or number of
products you'd like to receive per
per delivery is also something which we
we look into so when we talk about
customization
not simply the um modification
of the particle uh for a uh
like say a specific antibody we also
look into
optimizing that particle for your
workflow
typically the beads that we find
ourselves modifying
are the ceramic beads those are produced
in cardiff
of those those are also produced in
cardiff
and when we modify them we modify them
from
two of their particular functional
moieties
whether that be the carboxyl modified
beads or whether that be from the amine
blocked magnetic beads specifically the
carboxyl modified beads
we will use for capturing nucleic acids
just purely onto the surface
or whether that's modifying them to bind
on say
the an oligodt functionality or some
other oligo functionality
and they can also be used for
conjugating to
proteins or other
molecules of interest which have an
available primary amine group on the
surface
and we also offer that in a high-speed
version as well so you like i said
earlier we load on a second layer of
magnetite in order to
move allow them a particle to be drawn
to a magnet that much quicker
additionally to the carboxyl modified
particles
we have a further amine blocked particle
amine block specifically
so this now has a chemical blocking
functionality on the surface of the bead
this isn't a protein blocking um and the
primary surface
moiety on the front of the surface of
the bead is the aiming group
similar conjugation strategies can be
used
um typically con carboxyl aiming
conjugations are used quite readily
throughout this sector
um but also uh it will change the
surface charge of the bead as well so
you don't get quite get the same binding
of
nucleic acids to the surface of the
beads as you can with the carboxyl beats
for affinity purification dna
purification
and then i just wanted to have a little
talk about if you guys
uh working with our particles
just a few common
challenges to make when you are using um
ceramic particles or typically any
magnetic paramagnetic particles um
our beads are supplied in a 0.05
sodium azide preservative um
if you're doing conjugations yourselves
this will interfere with your
conjugations or maybe
also interfere with your application so
we recommend washing the beads
three times or more in your buffer of
choice be that conjugation buffer or
storage buffer
and when i mean by washing um
effectively it's a drawing down of the
bead onto a magnet
removing the supernatant allowing the
beads to
reconstitute into your buffer of choice
and repeating that three times it takes
a few minutes
but can really help with some
troubleshooting further downstream
additionally uh a large number of
antibodies which we'll buy buy from
common suppliers
are supplied in a high glyceral
concentration buffer for their stability
um in frozen conditions which will
enable them not to freeze
um when doing conjugations
for um or covalent conjugations with our
carboxyl beads that will need to be
removed so whether that needs to be
removed by a dialysis or some kind of um
buffer exchange technique um as
the glycerol will will interfere with
your conjugation methods
what what we do find for the ceramic
bees specifically
they're very soluble in waters or and
then many aqueous
solutions um but we do find that they
can stick
uh to the side of some plasticware um
not
none of the plasticware that we use
in-house in sativa and that's one of the
learnings that we have inside the
cardiff center and we're happy to share
whatever knowledge we have with with
yourselves
but we do recommend if you are doing
your own conjugations
and you intend to store them in an
aqueous buffer at the end
just typically add a small amount of
surfactant to those buffers which can
really help
stabilize the solution but also
encourage it not to stick to the surface
of any plastic where you may be using
additionally uh it's worth highlighting
the ceramic beads are very stable
in a wide wide range of ph of buffers
so you can go from very low to very high
ph's with the same beads and there's no
further
modification that you need to look out
for or risk of the particles
um suffering um throughout that
do be aware that if you have bound a
protein onto the surface of these
particles
that um large changes in ph can be
detrimental to the protein so
you you need to understand your uh your
application as well there
so we've got the last section here um
i've talked a little bit about um
the portfolio of where we make the
particles um
a little bit about um some applications
for our particles and then further
modifications of them
um that you may want to consider
for your own application specifically in
cardiff
is the customized solutions team which
again is what i'm part of
and we offer a series
of capabilities
around the genomics and diagnostics
portfolio
whether that be stabilizing of your
biological material or your sample or
even your
say master mix for lyo stable
whether that's to scale up your
application
into a kit or into uh or for further use
downstream
as as your business grows so we can do
formulations
inside the manufacturing facility
um whether you would like specific
conjugations of the particles
whether that's a specific oligo or
protein as i've described
earlier on in this presentation
we also offer dispensing and
custom modifications of plates within
our portfolio
and finally the manufacturing and
kitting of your
either product or or kit for
your downstream application so whether
that means that you particularly need
certain plastic wares in there or
certain dispense
volumes or even certain documentation
and branding on your products as well
these are all things that we handle
within the cardiff manufacturing site
probably good to highlight with the
title of this site
um for for your custom magnetic
particles and how they
they can help you um we run through a
number of steps
um to help your uh you realize
your custom conjugation this does start
with a number of questions about what
you're intending to do and typically we
have a technical call
with your technical lead uh or
yourselves
to just for you to have a chance to
describe what
you would like from the custom work
and then we also very openly describe
what we're capable of
and what we can deliver to yourselves so
in that early discussion can take a
a week or so and then we'll go through a
period of planning how we're going to
manufacture it
in the cardiff site um
we come back to yourselves to describe
what we have planned
and then move into a proof of principle
phase where we'll make a small
amount of the material we've agreed upon
in the planning and early discussions
and then return it to yourselves for
testing or even
share with you the data which has been
generated
during that proof of principle work
it's quite common for the proof of
principle to be multi-stepped as maybe
it's an iterative process
process between our capabilities and
your
realization of your product but
ultimately
we intend for that to lead to a final
product specification
and then with yourselves and with us we
will lock down the product specification
and engage with the manufacturing teams
in cardiff
um specifically on how to transfer that
product
into manufacture setting that up within
our electronic
resource management systems as well as
utilizing the full scale
of manufacturing uh within cardiff
this phase is typically called our
validation and verification
phase and so we'll go through a number
of challenges to your design
to our methods for making that design
um as well as setting up say artwork
specific bottles and labels
specifications for raw materials
so that can take a number of weeks to
get through but by the time
that that process is completed we will
be in the position to manufacture your
first
batches of custom products
and so that first batch will be
manufactured
um again if it's part of the validation
strategy you'll be
involved with that and we'll be involved
with this custom team as well as the
quality and the manufacturing teams on
site in cardiff
but ultimately it ends up with a place
where
you will have your product code to order
them
your custom product again and again um
as and when you want as if it was a
normal
product off of the site eva website
uh things which we're quite proud of in
cardiff is we're always open to audits
and site visits
um and in these challenging times as
well we're open to virtual
site visits and audits as well so please
talk to us
if you have any questions and queries
we're happy to happy to dig into them
we're proud of our iso 9001
accreditation and our quality
quality management system as well and
we're happy to run through that with
yourselves
um and also just finally
case it wasn't entirely clear this
process
that we have for many for making your
your custom conjugation
it's very much a collaboration between
the two groups
so we agree what's going to be made and
we share with you what is happening at
each step of the of the process
so that you can be involved and get the
product which you want
at the end of the day
so
just to give a quick summary of where we
have been
uh through this slide thank you very
much for your time um
and and for for listening in so
sativa has three distinct magnetic b
technologies the
uh maxepheros the ciramag and the
ceracilmag particles
um they are all supported by the custom
solutions team
custom services team in cardiff in the
uk
so please ask any questions
we are happy to work with yourselves
on what is possible from magnetic
particles and your application
and it's very common that with the
simplicity of using
the magnetic properties of these
particles and how
common and how uh capable they are
to bind different uh functions and
ligands onto the surface of them
we're confident that you can improve
your the street the
your laboratory workflow to help you
get more data from your samples or from
more samples
over time
so yeah just to highlight
that we can streamline your workflow
we can improve your sample preparation
within with regards to how quick it can
be
you can process your samples you'll get
higher purity as it's easier to remove
contaminants from the your solutions
and we can reduce the number of steps
you have in your protocols in
indeed speeding up your time at the
bench to get you more data
more rapidly so thank you very much for
your time
thank you for being part of this
presentation and i look forward to
taking any questions
thank you
tom thank you for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of our presentation
as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions via the q
a box okay tom let's we've got quite a
few questions already coming in let's
start with this question
are there limits to the scale possible
for the custom conjugations
think of that um it's uh
it's interesting we when when we uh
discuss
the custom opportunities for these
conjugations
we find a number of them align
with our current manufacturing processes
and we're quite open with any of our
discussions
about what the scale is possible so
typically um the the
the request is for a few milliliters
tens of milliliters and then obviously
there's a forecast and there's a demand
if this is going to become a
final product or something which is
going to be expanded to other groups
so we'll typically go from the tens of
milliliters
with an eye to scaling up to to a couple
of liters
of conjugation and that all lines up
with what we currently do in cardiff and
we do
we we have a number of discussions with
the manufacturing teams
with the research and development teams
to see how appropriate
your custom conjugation would be for
sort of that end goal to get you to the
to the scales you need to get to
and then we'll discuss inside the
project
with yourselves what
experiments validations may be required
to get us to that scale of conjugation
with the right quality and the right um
the the right uh kind of uh
price for you guys so yeah thank you for
that
great and thank you and while we're
talking about custom conjugations
are the custom conjugations appropriate
for use within a regulated sector
yeah thank you again yeah it's it's a
good one um
i think what the manufacturing site in
cardiff which is where
iron base which is where our team is
based where we make the ceramic beads is
an iso
9001 manufacturing facility but the
quality systems which are in place we
find are appropriate for a great
many of other um regulatory
requirements um so what we actually
asked
uh to do was the sort of the discussions
with
the customers with yourselves is to
uh review our manufacturing processes
our quality requirements
uh to see how appropriate they are for
your
regulated area you're working or moving
into or you are already
working within and that typically
actually covers um a site visit
or in at the moment a virtual site visit
so we've done a couple of them
over the last number of months as well
so we're quite open to having
um discussions about uh
what we do how we do it and whether
that's appropriate for your
product um going forward great
and let's just keep the ball rolling on
custom conjugations
how long does it look typical excuse me
how long does it typically
take for a custom conjugation to be
completed
thanks um so obviously
uh no maybe this isn't obvious we are a
small team so
this is quite this is this is what we
are in our custom team
um but we are supported by a large
manufacturing group
and a research and development group so
what
what we typically find is when we get
the raw materials on site um
when we've confirmed what the
manufacturing process is if there's any
outstanding questions
sometimes we've received and may i could
see other questions in there so
sometimes we've received um a different
paramagnetic particle so there's some
sort of
exploration and experiments to look at
the handling of that material
but i'd say once we have everything
nailed down we normally have
the conjugate made within two weeks and
shipping back to you for testing within
that amount of time so we'll
share tracking details and so on thank
you
sure and thank you um can you help me
with guidance on how to
conjugate my in-house developed protein
yeah so obviously there's
there's lots of considerations um
for a a protein and and
uh sort of um what's its stability
uh what its application and so on um
what i probably would
point you towards is there's there's
quite a good um
breakdown called magbeats 101 on the
sativa
website so you can google it or we can
email it to you after this discussion
but that has a good breakdown of
techniques and methods
um but also what you'll actually find is
if you get in touch with us
um give us a bit of a description about
what you can do whether there needs to
be
ndas in place or all those bits
and we'll discuss with you um
things we would do in-house
and i've got to say quite a lot of those
discussions we've had over the years
have actually ended up
us attempting the conjugation for you
just so you can have an idea of what
the um the performance might be um
that's quite a a collaborative approach
and again we try and be as open as we
can
um with regards to what we can share
um but also we we
i think certainly from my experience of
working within sativa within this group
i think we have a good idea of um
some of the the burdens to entry
for uh customers such as yourselves
so we try not to make that a financial
one we try and
get to the technical challenges as soon
as we can so i'll just say
talk to your local sativa rep there'll
be a modality specialist who will talk
to me
um directly and we'll
discuss your problem in technical detail
and we'll probably end up having a
technical call
um to sort of see what the options are
so
there's the website and there's contact
us directly and
you can have a chat with us um on a
conference call or something
thank you great tom thanks for that
information there are several
questions that came in regarding that so
you've really covered
um quite a few questions so thank you um
looks like we have time for just a
couple more
let's try to squeeze maybe two in do you
only
conjugate with ceramic family particles
this is a two-parter
and are you open to conjugating our
in-house made paramagnetic particles
yep thank you i kind of alluded to it
earlier
it has happened a couple of times um
where there is a specific
particle developed by yourselves or you
have one which you
would like to which is more appropriate
for your application
um we are open to that um
i i would say um some of the challenges
with conjugation of these magnetic
particles
is they can be quite sticky uh they
they may not be homogenous um or mono
dispersed
so i mean i i think
those are some of the real key positives
about the ceramic particles that they're
not sticky
they are mono dispersed um but but we
would be open
to um to getting your particles whether
that was a the particle you guys would
like to source and send it to us we can
talk about
what concentration they need to be in
and what functionality and buffers they
are stored in
or whether there's one from a catalog
you'd like us to source for part of the
conjugation or whatever so
we're open we're open to most things uh
with regards to that
but again always good to look at the
ceramic particles
they're quite they're quite good for
this sort of application sure
thanks tom and we have time for one more
question and i'm gonna go with this one
it's come in twice
can you ship custom conjugations to the
asia pacific
region yeah thank you
um so the shipping is
kind of a two-part answer so for the
custom conjugation specifically that's
with me and
my team we will drop ship so this will
be
um dhl express
we will consult with our um
customs custom support team and
regulatory teams to confirm
how we can ship whether we need to get
licenses etc etc
there'll be brokers at either end this
is quite common in shipping to
asia um so it can be quite a manual
process but yes we do it we do it
regularly
um it happens also very regularly with
the lyo stable
side of the business as well so we we're
very possible to do that i would also
just sort of like
close that one off is with the custom
conjugations
um when that does become a final product
like a product number you would buy from
sativa
that will have all of the regulatory uh
and the shipping terms all built into
the setup of that product
so that will go through a slightly
different logistics channel um
through the site the main sativa
logistics channel and be distributed
through worldwide hubs which would
include asia
as well so that one um it
would be uh there may be some more
discussion up front
but when you receive the material it
will be like ordering anything from the
site eva website
great thanks tom and i think that might
prompt some more questions and
i just want to remind our audience that
you know the questions that we're not
able to answer today and
um any questions that come in during the
on-demand period so
you know to our audience if you want to
come back and watch this on demand you
can submit questions and tom will be
able to answer them via email
so tom thank you so much for your time
today i want to thank our audience for
the
for their outstanding questions tom do
you have any final comments for our
audience
um i thank you very much for listening i
think it's a really broad subject
um we've tried to sort of pitch it
as a really broad overview of
magnetic beads and applications so if
there are any specific questions let us
know
and you may find that in some of the
booths we've got as well
for sort of nucleic acid isolation or
something like that or even just come
and visit us
in in the custom um and designing
booth that we've got open as well so uh
yeah hopefully speak to you later
yes and i'll piggyback on that we do
have the booths available and their
boots
there are booth reps in the booth right
now that you can have one-on-one chats
video chats um and with a live person
so feel free to visit our booths in the
exhibit hall
tom thank you again for your time today
i want to tell our audience that this
presentation will be available on demand
for 12 months
so please remember to share this with
your colleagues who might be interested
in today's
topic and don't miss out on our other
presentations on the agenda
the agenda tab in the auditorium will
provide a full listing
so thanks again tom thank you thank you
to our audience
everyone stay safe and have a great day
bye